Danica Patrick in studio and she's got
some nice high heels on you want to be
there there they are your pumps I I
liked how you walk past the desk I don't
get to show off my shoes there well
otherwise I had tennis shoes where
Danica Patrick in New York today to help
promote NBC's season launch of NASCAR
racing in the first Sprint Cup event of
2016 Saturday night the Coke Zero 400
from Daytona 7:00 Eastern Danica driving
the number 10 nature's bakery Chevrolet
for stewart-haas racing that's what I
should have brought I should have one
gracious bakery fig bars but you you
didn't when you're working overtime and
you need a little snack on the go with
that I'm like I'm like a promotional ad
you didn't bring any treats no I think I
have one in my purse if you need you can
we divvy it up for all my my guys over
there as well you bite-size yes I think
we could make eight small bites when you
walk around New York you get reaction oh
you don't walk around here no I ride
around New York and you don't think I
walk very far really there's a
restaurant around every corner you don't
need to walk very far if you did walk
what reaction do you think you would get
well it's challenging because I'm ready
to throw an elbow just like the next
person in New York City so looks I'd
probably get like jerk but um you mean
popularity like double recognize me or
what would they say to you I don't know
I don't really get a ton of that I'm
mostly I think I get a lot of this like
people walk and they walk by me and then
they go and they look at my butt Hey
look at you I think that it's like that
delayed reaction out of place and I'm a
lot smaller than people think I would be
and I know you critiqued my entourage
which I did not invite a little bit
impulsive I have one person I need the
other people are here for the fun of it
but I don't travel around like
pretentiously so I don't wear a hat I
don't wear something I mean we're
sunglasses if it's sunny out good
and I don't have a big group of people
and I don't need a bodyguard
I mean enough
but this attitude or is it just your
personality like do you have to almost
embrace that to be competitive to be
great I have to be this for such as you
yes I'm just curious what's the this
that you're just you're your persona
like the competitiveness that you have
to have that I'm not going to take any
nonsense I mean it doesn't feel like you
let your guard down when it comes to
true I think you I do I have learned
some of that like when I when I was
young and I was 16 when I moved to
England and raced cars over there and
moved away from home and left high
school I was pretty green and open and
you know honest and upfront and not sure
serve me very well so I think I learned
some of the some of the control but I
think if you're a true competitor it's
in you it's in me it's always been there
to be competitive to be feisty to be
strong as my people would call me or
other people probably have more
aggressive words than that but um but to
we it's just in me do we analyze your
personality because you're a woman more
than we would Tony Stewart or you know
Kevin Harvick or likely it's because
you're a woman in a man's sport
therefore we're sort of acknowledging
your competitiveness I don't know 100
percent you could tell me if you think
that like a given a certain incident
being similar what would the judgment be
but I would say in general I would think
that people expect a girl to be more of
a lady but you want to fight like can
you get to that I have I have had guys
tell me well how can I get mad I can't
it's not like I can fight you and I'm
like well who's throwing punches here
I'm not punching you like can't we just
throw verbal punches oh that's fine
right yeah I mean Matt Kenseth throws
punches or Brad Keselowski they throw
punches
I mean I'm up if I throw a punch you can
throw one right back pretty sure nobody
you could take Kasey Kahne though right
oh definitely there's a lot of mica take
the Casey's definitely won one of them
well I I should have probably taken care
of that
Fontana when he right reared me at 210
but I didn't instead instead he I think
he was a little scared for a little
while
I didn't say a lot of hellos oh but I
kind of wanted to keep him right there
but how clicky is that whole fraternity
well and a sorority of of the drivers
there when you go to these tracks you're
seeing the same people every single week
yeah and what happened last week and
then you go into the next week I mean
it's a it's pretty challenging - for me
to think that if somebody is a jerk on
the track that they're not kind of a
jerk in everyday life a little bit I
mean so it's really hard to separate
them so I do judge them off the track
based on their on track performance but
um yeah there's plenty to choose from
there's plenty of people to choose from
to be friends with you don't have to be
friends that you don't want to but do
you know the people who don't like you
no I don't I just know the people I
don't like I don't know I'm sure there's
a lot of people like I'm just not like I
can't Dan this is what I needed to make
sure I vote I prepared myself mentally
for this I knew you did I knew that I
could you could put me in positions that
I would regret so you're not going to
say because what you do not say brad
keselowski right actually the other day
we were racing in Sonoma and Saturday
was a pretty low day for things to do so
the afternoon is spent at the pool and I
hung out with Kyle Larson's a girlfriend
Caitlin because Kyle and Ricky were
golfing and Brad and Paige's girlfriend
and Joey and his wife Brittany and I
have not had issues with um with Brad
but I have one little one but we
rectified it very early on I I just
missed my braking so and it was really
my fault and I said sorry but I've had
issues with Joey so it's like again like
he's one of those drivers it's hard for
me to differentiate between like some of
the things you've done on track have
really been disappointing but yet you're
friendly off friendly here at the pool
today so it's tough would you rather
that they they weren't different like
that because then you go nice guy nice I
don't want him to be nice
I show them just not be a jerk on the
track that would be much easier well
then you have this situation where Tony
wins yes which is awesome but but here
he is you know bumping Hamlin and then
Denny goes I was so proud of you with
what you did because you were trying to
win a race well I I mean there are so
many times where people do things that
are really dumb and you know I I think
that they're not thinking straight like
there's a time and a place for things
like I was taken out by somebody ten
laps down at Michigan like there's a
time in a place and racing for racing
lead lap cars when you're ten laps down
is not the time in place to put yourself
in the middle of a situation but Tony I
I mean I was so happy for him and he he
text me back and said I'd used up the
eleven a little bit and I said buddy
there is a time and a place for all of
that and it is for the win so that
that's cool that then you understood
that and got that and I agree that's the
time in the place like you know ah a win
is a win and they're really really hard
to get and no matter what even if you're
Tony Stewart racing in your last season
so I can respect all of that but you
know lap 56 of 360 is probably not the
time stuff like that
Danica Patrick in New York today a
promoting NBC season launch of NASCAR
it's Saturday night the Coke Zero 400
from Daytona 7:00 Eastern the number 10
nature's bakery Chevrolet for
stewart-haas racing if you could pick a
track for the win I probably have to be
Martinsville for me I feel like I've
probably had the most success there I
used to I mean I really love speed ways
they're exciting but man it's a lot of
luck involved but in the beginning when
I didn't wasn't as good at driving the
cars on other tracks they were some of
my only chances so I fired a pick one
for the win um yeah I mean I think
Martinsville is a fun one anyway just
because you can kind of bump and move
people out of the way a little bit
what's the track that should not be in
the rotation for the entire championship
yeah it's there one that just you don't
like it or it's not safe or well
personally frustrating haha
um we race on a lot of mile-and-a-half
we probably could do without one of them
like oh I want names today - I know
you're really pushing me um if I guess
it will you tell me is there one that
you're bored of watching like where we
get strung out I think people by
Michigan I mean I think there's like a
Michigan or Kansas people can get
frustrated with because they're more
boring and they get more spread out
because aerodynamics matter a little bit
more so it's harder to get close to the
cars around you and I know that the
drivers in NASCAR try and work together
to try and make the setup of the car
make the rules package of the car
different to make it better for racing
but it's just hard it's it's just hard
to do so um I don't I mean they're all
very similar which is why I say the mile
and a half because you know when you say
a short track
well Phoenix is a lot different than
Loudon and Louden's a lot different than
Richmond so those vary a little bit but
the mile and a half Stender feel really
similar you still have doubters well
don't yeah I'm a bear in the woods comes
to mind really but it's because you
haven't wire the doubters still there
I mean you've proven yourself I would
say that they probably exist for
everyone on some level I mean I think
that once you get to a certain point on
the top top echelon of success they're
probably not necessarily as much
doubters as much as just people that
don't like you but I would say it's
pretty hard to get away from having any
any doubters at all uh so your boyfriend
is a NASCAR driver yeah yeah but it's
like acting that actors date actors did
you think that you know you were going
to we're still playing in the same movie
together so yes going well who's more
competitive um I have a hard time second
he could be in general me yeah yeah you
see your mouth the winds like when we're
on the golf course
yeah like it took him two years to
finally play music on the golf cart or
let me play mine now he plays his own
it's awesome he had he but he was very
very up in things like that he's very
I suck so it's just easy for me to be
like I like hit one into the sand and
I'll be like it's my time to shine look
at this watch this did you see that you
know and I'll just throw the ball
because it goes further when I throw it
throw it out of the bunker
yeah no no I yes I do sometimes would
you spin him out to win
you know I have a lot of judgment of
people who are willing to just purely
wreck somebody to get them out of the
way cut in any situation I just think
that's a cheaper way to do it I mean to
move someone is different I think that
you know if you work on them for a
little bit and then you need to move
them to get them out of the way I think
that that is fine and but spinning
someone out for the win I mean like if I
only had one chance yeah I mean I think
you kind of have to but yes yeah I don't
know I just such a cheap way you know to
just like ran them into the corner and
then I don't know but but what Stewart
did to Hamlin yeah you can do that yeah
well I mean it's not that easy I mean
I've clearly totally sucked at taking
people out when I've tried terribly oh
so you've tried to yes it's gone
horribly for me but if I said but I'm
still I make their day more difficult
but it doesn't mean that I don't have a
difficult day than to if you could help
Tony Stewart win a race mm-hmm or your
boyfriend I have to help my teammate
yeah absolutely it's a right answer yeah
yeah
Tony we're totally sorry same thing to
tony signing your checks there it is
we're like the Capulets and the
Montagues Ford and Chevrolet but it was
it won't it won't stay like that next
year but um we'll be we'll both be one
or the other
the impact with other women wanting to
do this for a living have you seen
anything where they look at you you know
with women with Sprint Cup or you know
what kind of legacy are you leaving here
you think just a good question I think
it's hard to know I think it's hard to
know when you're in the middle of it
sometimes I think it takes a little bit
of removal to reflect but you get
letters from girls um do this are they
our boys - oh you do um
and prison mail that one usually comes
to the home address though I hear break
big with the inmates anyway well move
along I don't think that's a good
subject to stay on for good kinds of
reasons but do I I mean I would hope I
leave the legacy to I would hope people
remember me that I'm a great driver that
I was a great driver when I'm done and
if they remember that I'm a girl's
second that would be nice but I hope
they remember me as a great driver and
holy crap she was a girl she'd really
well that that would be cool and
hopefully I would love to be a driver
that's won in IndyCar and NASCAR that
would be a cool legacy as well that's a
pretty short list mm-hmm I would hope
that I would hope that it just inspires
people to do whatever they want I'm not
necessarily trying to inspire girls to
be racecar drivers as much as I'm trying
to inspire people to be their very best
and to do whatever it is that they love
and go all the way with it so I I think
that you know my friends all laugh at me
but I just have this really simple
saying of try harder for everything like
I was doing it I was doing an interview
today about like fitness and that she
said what would you tell you know women
who are you know in the gym working out
of it try harder that's easy just try
harder try harder do better pretty I
tell myself that princey try harder
that's a great advice yeah try harder
for a change
serious it's great to see you it's
really great to see you later you were
gonna say something I was what I have a
gift for you you put in your man cave oh
you do oh paulie's always gonna go grab
it for me paulie's either leaving or
he's going to go get it oh they're all
it's the new cardboard cut-out
bandana I'm either the color of my skin
is different and by my skin I mean my
suit so if people want to know if that's
really the real height of me I do have
heels on but it's pretty close yeah I'm
it's pretty close yeah I like how tall
or
you five foot one and a half okay which
is kind of like I'm three and a half it
all matters at that height I like that
thank you
yeah you know I just don't want you to
ever forget about me with I can't I will
not take your I took your parking spot D
Patrick that was great when we did that
SportsCenter commercial and didn't you
fly up from Letterman yeah I think like
can you take a helicopter tour we sat in
the car for hours but we came to you and
it was very it was really cool it was a
Prius to be it was I was driving my
Prius it was and I was like that really
I know
oh I felt so small mezack lead the way
and green in the green direction oh
absolutely yeah I'm just trying to drive
now uh don't you have like a Tesla or
something or something I I Drive a ram
truck I Drive a Chevrolet you should try
the Ram truck you should try the Chevy
Tahoe I did I'll race you with my RAM as
long as you don't Ram me with your Ray I
think I'll win let's uh we'll race for
uh pink slips here we'll exchange some
paint perhaps okay yeah I'm not afraid
I'm not going I'm not either I I get the
feeling like competitively you and I
would probably but hey we would probably
kill each other yeah but you said you
want to get back into yoga so I'm really
excited to if I were to do yoga did that
privately well I was off the record well
it's the whatever feel like everything's
on the table with you so anyway I feel
like competitively you and I in yoga
would be funny cuz I would be a lot
better ah and I'd love to see you try
don't work dog it starts there yeah at
all I'll tell me about it
Danica Patrick the Saturday LEM Coke
Zero 400 from Daytona International
Speedway 7:00 Eastern it's the number
ten nature's bakery Chevrolet for
stewart-haas racing thanks again for
coming in thank you man so good to see
you yeah my daughter Danica Patrick
and Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience